i never thought they'd put a bucky scene
in a dc tv show but
well not my proudest one oh hey didn't
see you there uh
how's it going so the finale of doom
patrol season two has just dropped
and throughout this video we're gonna be
breaking down everything that you need
to know about the ending
obviously there will be heavy spoilers
here so if you haven't had a chance to
check out the final episode yet
then i highly recommend that you turn
off now you better subscribe to the
channel
as we do videos like this every day and
also yeah please drop a thumbs up if you
enjoy the video
with all out the way welcome to the
heavy spoiler show
this is the death patrol now let's get
into the breakdown
okay so season two has very much
centered around the relationship
between dorothy and her dad niles i kind
of feel like
this season has focused a bit too much
on her and with the finale being cut
short due to covid it does feel slightly
underwhelming
now that's not to say it's bad but you
can definitely feel the pandemic forcing
the creative team to
cut a few corners in order to try and
wrap this up in a satisfying way
now throughout the series we've had some
interesting plot elements
such as cliff trying to build a
relationship with his daughter
cyborg getting a new love interest and
ria trying to create a career in showbiz
once more
lawrence also very much sees the truth
behind his relationship with his family
and the season as a whole thematically
centers around the children and their
parents having to make good on their
mistakes
there's more family motifs here than a
fast and furious film
and i really got the feeling that it was
about the doom patrol casting aside the
family that they had biologically
in favor of the one that they formed as
friends that's all kind of surface level
stuff
but it does feel laced throughout the
entry there's there's also a good bit
with steel and stone in episode five
that was
probably probably the height of the
season and you know what that avengers
parody in episode eight
in case you don't know that used to be a
crime fighting tv show
and it's actually the reason that the
avengers movie had to be called avengers
assemble in the uk
a little bit of trivia for you there
that i'm sure you don't care about now
the more we learn about dorothy
the more we discover how dangerous she
could be
dorothy has the ability to bring her
imaginary friends to life
and throughout the season the evil
candle maker slowly starts to manifest
in the real world
now in the comic books the candle maker
was actually created through unconscious
tensions
that arose in the wake of the second
world war the planet was in a constant
state of paranoia
and whether it was countries developing
nukes the cold war
or people thinking we would never see
the snyder cut
this anger manifested into the character
through dorothy's abilities the
candlemaker saw a way to come into our
reality
and by posing as an imaginary friend it
snuck in with the creatures that existed
in her mind
waiting for the perfect opportunity to
break free that's pretty much the basis
of how it came to be
and we watch as niles tries to stop
dorothy from maturing and unleashing
what could be the apocalypse
now though niles has tried his best to
stop her from growing due to the
repercussions it could have
the character gets a period in episode 8
to show that she's indeed aging
this blood coming on also acts as a
metaphor for the bloodshed that the
candle maker will bring forth
and as always doom patrol kinda kind of
uses things we don't normally talk about
in the open
to signal the way things are gonna go
cliff also learns that he will have a
grandson
and gets a wedding invite and we also
discover that cyborg's girlfriend
is a suspect in an fbi investigation the
two go their separate ways
with borg likely having to go after her
due to her fugitive status
rita gets a chance to stop her but
doesn't but you know what i'm not mad at
her
you go beekeeper lawrence and jane also
go on a mission to find a primary
personality
in order to inhabit the latter's body
and it's here that miranda is able to
slip in and take over
i'll talk about this later in the video
but it's something important to bear in
mind
elsewhere niles and dorothy go to a fun
fair in what could be their last day
together
here she has a vision of a mother who
tells her that it's time
she transports her to their home and i
love the little inclusion of the red
boots
dorothy of course wore ruby slippers in
the wizard of oz
and these granted her the wish to return
home i actually think that they may be
used as a way to grant a wish for doom
patrolled dorothy
and they will likely be the key to
defeating the candle maker now these
boots
also have another meaning when she's in
the bathroom
the show hovers on our white trainers
and the blood that appears on them
the fact that we go from the red blood
on her trainers to her red boots
showcases that she's growing as a person
and is now ready to take on a bigger
role
how to make matters worse niles starts
to succumb to his sickness
due to losing his immortality and the
stakes really rise as we head into the
finale
the candlemaker manifests at the
carnival and the doom patrol
are called in to save the day this
causes issues for cliff who promised to
be at the birth of his grandson
but because of the bigger matters at
play he's unfortunately called away
i do think that he will get this
opportunity in the 10th episode
but the way things are left yeah it
doesn't seem too good for him
now upon arriving at the carnival
kipling is taken away
and they're attacked by their imaginary
friends rita comes face to face with a
collage that she made as a child
who's also known as roxy this was her
idea of beauty
and as she's become someone whose looks
led to her going on an internal downward
spiral
it's cool to see her face off against it
we learn that the eyes she used
actually belonged to her mother but that
she cast roxy to the side after the two
became estranged
due to her let's say discovery i'm
trying to keep it as pg-13
as i can now cyborg faces off against a
version of his father
also known as dr cowboy and cliff
against jesus
the last one is hilarious and it lets us
know that cliff's family
were probably bible bashers when the guy
was younger
jane or rather miranda who is of course
pretty much built upon multiple
personalities
takes an inward journey into her own
mind and remembers
the first time that she lost control
this was because of her boyfriend
who tried to host an orgy in order to
add some spark back into their
relationship
but she never saw her as missing
anything and thus was completely torn
apart by it
miranda felt uncomfortable because of
what was going on and it's at this
moment that she stepped back as the
primary personality
though i thought she would have been
used to having multiple people inside a
yeah you're having that now we learned
at this moment is what fractured miranda
in chain completely
and that it allowed the latter to step
forward and become the primary
personality
over her however there does come a big
twist with this
as we do learn that miranda stepped back
and killed herself in the show
the miranda that we've seen isn't really
miranda
and it is possible that it may be some
facet of jane's father
now we don't know that for definite and
yeah there's very little to go on
but let me know your thoughts in the
comments below as it's something i'd
love to discuss
this is the moment that made jane take
center stage and guide the group
but as we learn this false miranda has
now taken back control
now the candlemaker is of course the one
causing their imaginations to run wild
in the real world
and it showcases the power that he's
come to possess the showdowns at the
patrol have
leads to them being covered in wax and
cliff is shattered
whilst the rest of the group are frozen
in place niles crawls along the floor
dying and dorothy comes out of hiding to
find him and a mother
she has the choice to sacrifice herself
or not but
she puts on the red boots and thus the
candle maker comes forward
her mother goes to give her a weapon but
instead she forms a staff
and she goes to the villain and is
pulled into a fire which is when nile
screams dorothy
and we cut to black now what exactly is
going on here
well in the original candle maker arc
dorothy actually defeated the character
by using wishes i think that in the
reality she's just been pulled into
she will use his power to take him down
and niles might actually end up joining
her
sacrificing himself to save his daughter
dorothy manifesting a cool spear
shows that the childish side still
exists within her
but that she's also able to pull on her
own powers and bring things from her
imagination into the physical form
i think in the show that the channel
maker exists very much like pennywise
and that due to it being a creature that
preys heavily upon the imagination of
its targets
that in order to defeat it one must use
that as a weapon
with dorothy still being a child i
imagine she's got a brilliant
imagination
and she can massively pull from this and
it will hopefully lead to a big shout
out between the pair
now this of course was not supposed to
be the finale and thus
it is difficult to really talk about the
ending as it's incomplete
however i do think that in the dimension
that dorothy's been taken into
we will see her imagination come forth
alongside her greatest fears now there
are lots of theories that
dorothy is actually dead but i disagree
with that
and i think niles will instead take her
place his arc this season has shown us
how much of a bad dude that he is
and i think it would be fitting that in
his final few moments he actually did
the right thing
obviously as soon as the next episode or
rather the real finale is here
i will have a breakdown on it but for
the moment those are my main thoughts
and theories on where things could be
going
now i'd love to hear your thoughts on
the season so comment below and let me
know
and also if you enjoyed this video then
please drop a thumbs up
and make sure you check out our
breakdown of season 2 of the umbrella
academy which is going to be linked at
the end
also shout outs to beyond gaming who
have been going back and forth with over
the season for the last couple of hours
i know he's got some big doom patrol
videos coming soon so definitely check
out his channel
don't forget that every month on the
15th we give away free blu-rays
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning the mcu infinity saga
boxset is
leave a like and subscribe with
notifications on if you want to support
the channel and get to see content early
then please consider clicking the join
button below you can also come chat to
us on our discord server
linked in the description or heavy
spoilers on twitter thanks for making it
until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been
definition i'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you